and then yeah this is the obvious this
is called nutting during fan causes i've
popped i made a video about this you can
watch it yeah yeah it's really old now i
i know the story but you can
yeah so essentially there was this time
where
i was doing uh fan call as hetalia
where's she that sounds like cringe
already yeah so i was doing it i was
doing it with someone else who was doing
another voice
and we were on the call with the person
and i thought
like there's some weird breathing sounds
coming from them but like
i was like huh this is a little weird
but i didn't think much of it was in
melon
you bring a decky mackerel of someone
from like vampires
so like yes so like what happened was
that we were on this call i thought
that's weird then when we got off the
call it was only like six seven minutes
all right i was like was that was that
weird that call was weird right
you're like oh no i don't think so but i
was editing the audio yeah so i go back
and listen to the audio
and i'm like she's definitely nothing
that ain't like that isn't like
that isn't like hyperventilating breath
that is like it was like slow
deep breaths
[Applause]
like that and i was like what the [ __ ]
so i made a video about it but i i pitch
shift it and changed it and it sounds
even creepier
it sounds like a two-year-old yeah oh
god it's scary because i wanted to
protect their
you know protect their identity
obviously because right i don't know if
it was i don't know if it wasn't but
like
yeah we don't say it don't sound good
yeah yeah yeah but yeah there was all
that i had
cut a lot of people oh that's a bit of
yikes there yeah yeah
how did you handle that you just you're
playing character right so you
i'm would you when you do those calls
you're in character so like when people
would say stuff i would reply as if like
in character like to reject them i just
i just like to imagine he's just like
you just hear like
oh no which italian character were you
playing i was playing france from
italian
but he's like he's like i've never
watched italia
but i assumed he was like a bit of a
player from what i understood but
i would i would have loved it if he was
playing like italy and he was just like
they were playing france they were
playing yeah they were playing italy
yeah and like to be fair it would happen
fairly often but i nearly always cut
them because it was just cringe
yeah yeah you feel like i want to date
somebody sebastian and i'd be like no no
no no one is worthy of me like that i
would like because i would reply because
because like it's really like dude when
you're cause i wear them in the zone and
i would do these calls like i would like
fully believe in that moment that i was
like that like
because you have to if you want to do it
good i mean you're you're playing a
character yeah
yeah yeah yeah so when people would say
stuff like that i would just like
snorkily just insult them straight away
because they loved it yeah like it was
and it was fun
like everyone dude imagine being an
[ __ ] i was like oh my god he's
amazing how long did you do this for
these calls yeah i did them for like two
three years how is this how
no because when it was when it went well
it was really fun because people had
such a genuine like
happy response really great it was just
you had to just deal with some weird
[ __ ] that's fast
fairly often yeah um and so i was like
all right i'ma head out
like this like the stock image uh from
that
that call am i right i'm only joking you
and you're probably never that bad right
yeah no no she was
she still is she is worse
i've seen her when she gets around to no
prince
all right next is the uncomfortable as
if and none of them were right yeah
right
the last one wasn't uncomfortable uh no
i can deal with that okay because that's
in character yeah that's not connor
that's sebastian that's france that's
not microsoft
that's francis she's getting real hot
for france
um so yeah the so i i up until very
recently i used to do patreon phone
calls and uh
not in character no it's me yeah yeah so
i would offer
and it's gonna sound like a lot for like
a hundred dollars an hour uh to have a
call with me but then if you ask any
youtubers around our size they'll be
like wow that's too little
yeah because it's just i know it sounds
absurd it sounds stupid my parents all
thought it was dumb they were like
people
people pay to speak to you connor that's
absurd my parents got the same reaction
why would anyone want us to pay to speak
to you connor like mum [ __ ] off mama
so anyway up until recently i used to do
patreon fan calls like like i said
uh i have like i'd call it like
generations i don't really know why
but people would always leave in mess
and join a mess and there was only 10
spots on
my course so yeah ten people at a time
could clear these calls all right um
and i would only maybe have like one
person who was on it for like two plus
years but the rest of the time is like
rotating people
and like i had some really [ __ ]
uncomfortable ones that i haven't really
spoke about because i'm just like this
is so [ __ ] weird but i mean maybe
i'll speak about it now yeah so this is
one time this is by far the most
uncomfortable
um where i'd done two calls with a
person and they were like okay they were
like oh all right that seemed pretty
decent seemed pretty normal they were
from
from vegas you know okay represent yeah
i don't know why you're pointing at me
and uh they were like sorry i didn't do
webcam it was only ever a voice but one
time they were like can we do webcam and
i was like all right
sure i mean what a one-off right like
i'll
what what's the worst that could happen
yeah of course yeah
yeah you guys know what happened yeah so
and i'm like okay sure sure let's do it
let's just do webcam whatever you know
you've been you've been on the patreon
for a while we can do this so
we boot up the the call i turn on my
webcam
shoot on she turns on her webcam uh yeah
she's naked
she's fully naked but wearing like body
paint but like you can like put the look
on ash's face
luckily you know she was over age which
is dodged
thank god otherwise finna get arrested
immediately i was like
yo what the [ __ ] and then i was like oh
oh no
the connection's breaking up and then
like they're like can you hear me
i was like i was like gosh i'm going
through the tunnel oh yeah
literally literally the moment it
happened like it flashed on the screen i
was like smash the red
red [ __ ] end disc before i was like
[ __ ] man you know how hard british
internet man it keeps going out
oh yeah i'm so mad at them man oh i know
you've got to say i got to stay on voice
just imploded so i was like [ __ ] that's
awful it was terrible
and i had some other uncomfortable
things come up and yeah generally just
just not very good things happen that
was just like why why are they doing
this like they were just hit on you in
really uncomfortable ways and
you know and to the point where it was
just like you know some people were
think
would think that you know you would meet
some people
who had clearly never been rejected in
their less their circle right
yeah and that they pay they pay me to
talk to me and then i'm like
well i've never been rejected so it's
it's not going to start now right
they think i'm going to like well i'm
i'm this is a work thing for me i'm
there doing business you know
it sounds like you had a [ __ ] babe
station call center
honestly it's cause like it's great 90
people it was chill it was just talking
to them get maybe give them a bit of
youtube advice maybe help them with
things
super normal calls it's just like some
people were like bro this is my
end this is my way to get to get like
connor to like hang out with me
or stuff and like i know all sorts of
weird [ __ ] like people would go around
and um like i think recently i i used to
do like voice recordings
i still do to be fair yeah they're
really easy but people would go around
take the voice recordings and say look
me and connor are best friends
like connor connor i have a message from
connor saying hi to me
yeah we're kind of like best friends and
i'm like do people know like why do
people do this
why do you think you're getting clout
are you comfortable with that
that's whatever i wouldn't be
comfortable i would not because i don't
know
that that that's me someone going around
saying that their friend of mine to like
get their way is like not good yeah
i mean it's it's also you know it's big
brain because you know i could be like
anytime i let's say right god forbid i
say something stupid on a live stream
we're like no no that's just recording
it just recording it patreon recording
not me
i'm kidding well now when conan gets
cancelled
i'll be like guys no that was just that
was the script just watched
just watch this one clip get linked
i never record anything inappropriate
yeah it's just like obviously
because some people want like a a an
uplifting message
down recently and i'm more than happy to
do that because i'm like you know if me
giving you a voice message saying hey
man just just
you know things will get better just
just keep trying i mean i've i've done
that before as well
but at the same time if i found out that
that person oh my god i don't like the
voice of messages anymore
was going around telling people hey i'm
best friends with giggles i'm impressed
friends we've gone and i'm just like
okay
get the [ __ ] out of my life please i
mean that's right
i emailed them basically saying hey uh
yeah yeah
i'm removing you from patreon what the
[ __ ] you doing this is sad
like yeah like well yeah of course
that's not cool because it wasn't
the worst thing was that she wasn't
going around to like her close friends
for some reason she was going around
sending them to other youtubers
oh saying i'm friends with connor look i
have this message and
unfortunately some of those youtubers
didn't know that i was doing the patreon
but i mean i i've gone through that as
well where i've had people going around
saying that they know me and saying that
they it happens
i've been friends with me when they
weren't just to try and get in with
other people and yeah
it's like that's that's the biggest
[ __ ] red flag for me but that's why i
that's kind of one of the big reasons as
well as time is why i removed the
ability to call me on patreon i don't do
it anymore you can't have a
phone call with me i mean i i think the
worst thing that happened to me was it
literally happened to me at a convention
where you know i had a guy who was going
around telling people
telling companies that they knew me and
that that they were they were trying to
use that as an inn that's
that's that's somehow even worse isn't
when they're going around to like
because they're potentially ruining your
name yeah yeah exactly but they're also
trying to profit themselves yeah
i can deal with someone being a [ __ ]
creep i can that's that's insular i can
i can i can just immediately shut that
down
right someone does that that's repairing
i have to do yeah yeah that's horrible
yeah luckily you know i guess that's why
it triggers me so much because i i hear
that i'm just i just think
like the [ __ ] i had to deal with the
audacity of this [ __ ]
i would gladly have someone hit on me on
a call a hundred times
rather than them go to a company saying
that we're friends yeah you know what i
mean because
i can you know that's fine don't do that
do do not do that
that is the biggest [ __ ] move you
could do we have gone in uh
50 years it's like
i don't know what the stock image is
what the [ __ ] did you get this image
from
i don't know what is this is this like
asian humpty dumpty
you type in egg okay